okay
you guys know my wife makes these awful
creations
but i have a secret confession to make i
love cursed creations
it's something that i actually collect
in my spare time
if i find a cursed image i know i gotta
save it i don't know what i'm gonna do
with it i just got
i gotta have it on my hard drive i have
a fine taste
in cursed images all right so therefore
we're gonna look at
boss fight universe this might seem a
bit like a weird tangent but trust me
this reddit is great it's got a ton of
weird ass
and i for one love it pick your fighter
we have gilgamesh the consumer of
reality
or maurice choose wisely
you see a young feline attempting to
gain strength
am i the only one ah is he's only doing
it for me
all right we'll get you you see a man in
the middle of a riot even shouting back
all of you get back single-handedly
fighting up the police with a chain whip
motherfucker's got a chain whip you come
across a scene
where it seems one of two comrades had
fallen in battle
how hard wrenching wrecking i can't
speak english
as you head through a room you see the
walls are spinning
and a bunch of people are trapped on the
walls as they spin one figure however
looks down at you from the wall he's
broken free from the chains that holds
back mankind
he is the chosen one the true bass boy
[Music]
wait a minute wait wait oh okay i get it
yeah what have you done
if you win i'll move here but if you
lose then i get your skeleton
fair fair trade what are you gonna do
with it i don't know yet
you realize that there's a portal below
you with something waiting for you
inside
my god i don't think i found anything
safe worthy yet but i'm hoping
oh my god well there you go speak of the
devil you see a lonely merchant waiting
for customers
he might be selling some potions but no
armor available unfortunately
his arrival was foretold in the ancient
murder
is that real that's so cool i like that
that's almost safe worthy
you made it to the final boss but first
enough
[Music]
okay but where where are we going earth
is done
late at night you pass some garbage bags
when suddenly
you hear a wrestling sound no
no i can't fight three of them at the
same time
you see him at nerf war you know you're
dead at sight
there's no fight give up immediately he
challenged you to defeat him
wait what the [ __ ] am i looking at uh
it's a shame about the
about the tag here otherwise it'd be
safe worthy you come across an old
adventure
who can't seem to completely squares
anymore
does that mean no no no
yo while on walk you encounter god of
wiggins
he can levitate if you wish the trees
and planes are on his side
but the animals he can't seem to control
them lift bar
to create a mass extinction you see a
bar will you flick it
yeah yeah obviously obviously mass
distinction
okay let's go defeat bounce the dog who
has the biggest health bar than free up
the bbc
bounce he's too powerful he's got too
much health
he's a god damn tank he can't be
defeated don't fight bounce
don't just bounce around you won't be
able to even hit him she may look
innocent but she's got
she got anger and fear in her eyes and
she will afflict it upon thee
you see scared boy or being threatened
by angry boy
such a cute image how does his flesh
just go out like that what the [ __ ]
he's got loose teeth or something hey
michael is that you
michael the imposter michael no
that's kind of success i don't think
it's michael though that's his personal
preference you encounter depression pond
you can't seem to make it out of this
place it's dark and dreary
you hear someone say up here dummy and
see this
but you can't slam dunk your sofa [ __ ]
huh
prove to me that you can slam dunk a
sofa and i'll give you the next quest
in on your journey i have so many ques
you know what that's safe worthy i'll
give it
a fine addition to my collection i think
that i think that's the beauty in these
images
it's like how do these come about like
this guy
it's the lore behind it the mom holding
the phone
him being still ripped as [ __ ] it's
funny
life you take some time off to cool down
like why how when what where it's i love
it
the internet is so such a confusing
place there it is you encountered god
the brass section
his armor is too strong don't even try
to defeat him
obama would like to access the
microphone never
ever under any circumstances let obama
access your microphone if he slides in
your dm
it's all good though i was supposed to
talk to this embassy for part of a
question
but he bugged me
god damn i hate when that happened so i
can't do the quests now
shake that's cool i like that i'll see
you later
where did this importantly nice
you know what that lake is missing water
you have approached lonely crab he
appears to be weeping
what will you do seduce or devour the
choice
is yours maybe both can i pick both
seduced then devour him for lonely crab
he never knew what was gonna happen
mr b's new campaign be looking like
bomb nature with trees [ __ ]
nature vessels
oh my what you find something growing
out of
your computer what do you do devour or
seduce
the choice is yours before it devours
and seduces you
that do be looking kind of sexy though
i'll say that oh
a classic image y'all y'all y'all too
young for to understand this
the cs lan parties we had as kids man
all you can do now is just bring a
laptop for your switch but no no no
there was dedication back in the day you
enter a door to a dungeon
and find the following on the inside
what do you do the bower
seduce the choice yours you are calm in
your house
you see your dog you smile at him and he
smiles back
what do you do devour seduce oh no he's
already seduced me he's so
cute that is that actually strangely
looked like the
middle point of devouring seduce not
knuckle ally saved
welcome very traveler to my shop buy or
sell we have a fine edition of swords
for you today
yeah the greatest weapon of pain
what is it there's a belt on a what this
is legit what i do when i'm bored i go
through reddit's anyway
oh oh it's you spank em with it okay got
it okay
[Laughter]
which group of npcs should i help see i
have no idea why this photo was taken or
where or why
i i love it the cops have loot but the
sonic will give you
wish wait what got 100 dislikes i gotta
see that
what about sonic is wise you're low
level as [ __ ]
jesus christ dude he approaches you onto
your property from the forest
young traveler you must wear this armor
protect yourself from the five g's
i would spare you some but i used it all
for for my ass
monsieur
whoa
all right that was very unexpected worth
fighting or not is too powerful
there's no way you could win against
minecraft tyler1
the second stage of the boss is too
powerful oh
these are so cool like barely any power
and it just like
snaps like oh god
imagine imagine that getting on your
nipple
mighty one no oh [ __ ]
it's corpse irl finally
face reveal i knew it second phase cut
scenes be like
oh you thought you defeated me
peacocks are real-life boss battles i
knew it
[Music]
you dare challenge me
[Laughter]
oh that's great is that a real statue
that's such a cool edit
you walk down an alley and see this he
offers a limited time quest to kill his
arch rivals recycle man do you accept
absolutely i want to try that you think
i can do that
that's like an easy halloween costume
[Music]
fight me mortal it's a little hard to
breathe in this don't do that
why don't you help me i need help
help how did that look like
all right our trash bags are a little
small i ordered the wrong size
feels good man i don't really need to
wear pants
yeah i like this yeah oh
sorry don't look
as you enter a room you see that rather
strange game going on as two men seems
to be losing
he's too powerful we bet all our lives
on this
someone did this congratulations you
can you believe uh people sing so loud
the way people embarrass himself
ridiculous
who's he making ah yeah
[Laughter]
what what holy [ __ ]
fire rags
there plus five fire damage right there
these dudes look like that kind of boss
battle where you fight two
bosses at once and one will revive the
other
yeah they look ridiculous in those
outfits i look good
i feel fancy forbidden mcdonald's burger
must resist eating at once it could give
you extra health
or could come with unforeseen
consequences will you devour or seduce
it
the choice is yours okay guys this has
been boss fight universe
i have to return to my kingdom at once
to deliver the message
i see you on the other side
[Music]
ah